well next our nation our parent company
is partnering with a nationwide effort
to tackle hunger in every community
our kirsten joyce explains how you have
a chance to make a difference with this
special collaboration
the pandemic has drastically shifted the
urgency and need at food banks around
the country
to help people put food on their table
and what we're learning right now is so
many that we're serving
have never needed food assistance before
you can help this year with the super
bowl of caring
it began 30 years ago in a church in
south carolina with one prayer on super
bowl sunday
to be mindful of those who don't have a
bowl of soup to eat
the youth at that church took that on as
a as a challenge
and they asked the question what if
everybody watching the big game just
gave a dollar or one can of food
and if you look at that today that would
be a hundred million dollars in one day
executive director allison reese says
they've raised more than 163 million
dollars to date
a small organization with a large
network
due to the pandemic they began looking
at how technology can assist with this
year's efforts
they created the tackle hunger map you
use the search bar to find
charities in your neighborhood zip code
or city to encourage thinking about
giving locally
through churches homeless shelters
pantries and food banks
most people don't know where their
nearest food charity is
and that's something that we're trying
to address
using our map super bowl of caring
doesn't deliver food directly it acts
more like a catalyst
by infusing the money into the food
charities across the nation
and with next our nation's outreach this
year the nonprofit hopes you will help
raise
more than one million meals
just a little bit goes a long way and
that was our kirsten joyce reporting you
can help out our food bank right here in
las vegas which is three square
but also by going on to that tackle
hunger map kirsten was just talking
about you can click on any charity right
in your neighborhood
donate to any non-profit and it will all
count toward
that big super bowl of karen goldeneyes
yeah david so we're going to be raising
money for food banks during our new
year's eve special thursday night
all the money donated will stay right
here in las vegas
so that show kicking off at nine o'clock
running through 12
35 and our team will take you through
every time zone
starting in new york and ending of
course here in las vegas we will be live
along the las vegas strip in downtown
las vegas
with live performances and everyone will
be social distancing
doing cobid screenings and following all
the guidelines to stay safe